deputy pm is with us now also justice
secretary dominic rob mr rob good
morning to you thank you very much
indeed for joining us can we start with
ukraine if possible please um russia is
saying that they uh don't want to put
kiev at military risk and so they're
going to move their troops away how much
faith are we putting in those words well
i don't think a lot
we judge
the russian military machine by its
actions not just its words there's
obviously some skepticism that it will
regroup to attack again
rather than seriously engage in
diplomacy or anything of that nature um
of course the the door to diplomacy will
always be left ajar but i don't think
you can trust what is coming out of the
mouth of putin's war machine
to that end talking about diplomacy what
do we make of suggestions that the
ukrainian peace mission were poisoned
well look we've seen those uh very
credible reports we don't know uh a huge
amount about the the contextual detail
to it but it's very worrying um and
we're looking to clarify the situation
with our allies
talk to me about suggestions that uh
mercenaries from syria are being
recruited at seven thousand dollars each
to fight for the russians
well we've heard all sorts of um uh
reports of that we know uh that the
russians have a long history and are
very prevalent around the world in
deploying mercenaries uh they've done it
hired hands if you like as you suggested
the the wagner group is very well known
uh libya in particular but across africa
um
and of course in the context of ukraine
um and it is a warring sign but it also
probably
shows you how dependent they've become
uh on other fighters because of the
weakness and the fragility of the forces
the professional forces and their
reliance on conscripts which we're
starting to see play out a bit in
ukraine certainly the the russian war
machine which had a a pretty fearsome
reputation has been found to stutter and
stumble in at least the early stages of
this campaign so it is probably also a
sign of weakness or fragility okay is
there anything that the west can do
about it
look it's very difficult we'll have to
address that um we've known that there
are asymmetric forces so uh hired uh
mercenaries as well as conventional
forces in russia um they're a whole
range with russia you have to deal with
a whole range of of possibilities we set
that out in our integrated review you've
got the the fact that they hire
mercenaries they've got the fact that
they engage in cyber the fact that they
engage in
poisoning we've seen that in the past as
well the whole gamut comes with russia
and that why it is such an
unconventional adversary but actually
why i think the uk with our allies are
well placed because we do look at every
aspect of the uh of the battle and the
struggle
you've been to the hague recently to try
to start to talk about uh war crimes
that's a long process it will be a long
process but we're trying to lead the way
if you look at the response to ukraine
we've got sanctions uh we've got the
humanitarian response and relief we've
got the visas position on top of that
the pm i was very keen with the foreign
secretary and myself that we support the
international criminal court which is
looking at the allegations and the
reports of war crimes in ukraine so the
uk and i went out to the hague and we
offered support we've offered uh
financial and technical support to the
icc prosecutor on top of that last
thursday i hosted a meeting in the hague
38 countries joined and we said on the
base of our package what can we do
together to make sure that there is no
impunity for war crimes uh in ukraine
the icc prosecutor was there and i think
is a good example of where again the
britain is leading the way and you're
right it will take some time yeah i mean
the will is there but it's very
difficult to prove a war crime it is so
things like satellite imagery not just
to prove the crime but who's responsible
for it preserving evidence in a in the
fluid situation of a war zone is very
difficult which is why that support is
important now it's about what we can do
now to preserve that evidence and that
also tells the commanders and putin
himself everyone in between that they're
at serious risk of ending up in the dock
of a court and behind bars if they
engage in further war crimes or indeed
for any other action that they've taken
are you confident that war crimes will
be proven at the end of this war in
ukraine
well this is for the icc to decide but
we've been here before in yugoslavia and
rwanda
in sierra leone and the uk has got a
long history dating back to nuremberg of
supporting war crimes accountability and
again the prime minister has
with me and with the foreign secretary
led the way in saying we must have no
impunity for war crimes in ukraine is
that a yes do you feel that some people
will be held accountable with war i
certainly hope so i think for any crimes
there should be accountability and i
think that message needs to go out now
and what we hope is it will have a
deterrent impact on those commanders
that are at risk of facing illegal
orders to
engage in attacks which will harm
civilians meantime back home you're also
bringing in new legislation today tell
us about that well we're announcing
the outcome of our root and branch
review of parole there have been a
number of celebrated cases which have
created huge concern anxiety for victims
and the public we think of the war boys
case colin pitchfork and we said we
would
we said that we would do a root branch
review i'm announcing the details of
what were our proposals today they will
look at everything from the role of
victims i think their voice should be
heard more clearly during the probe
process but above all particularly for
dangerous offenders i want to make sure
the
process is re-anchored back into the
primary and overriding focus on
protecting the public particularly for
the top tier of more dangerous offenders
where the risk and assessing risk of
what they might do in the future is so
difficult to predict with any precision
okay you mentioned the visa applications
the homes for ukrainians only a thousand
people have been allowed in so far i
believe that's what the minister was
telling us yesterday i think it's a
thousand applications i understand per
day and we're going to this week set out
the the data so people can see how many
non at the moment no i don't know the
answer because we're about to publish
the data i think there's 200 000
sponsors that have come forward my
understanding is that around a thousand
applications are processed per day
you're right asking well yeah about how
many have actually been offered that
data is now going to be put forward very
shortly understand okay talk to me about
partygate here it comes um we've heard
from the police they made a statement um
how significant
is it that they've started to issue
fines
well i think uh we said that we needed
to have the independent zugre review we
respected that the met would be free to
of course um follow its investigation uh
they've come forward and up there and
and made clear that there are 20 fixed
penalty notices so far so good so far
and uh that the prime minister has
already been clear he's a uh taken
responsibility for the things that
shouldn't have happened in number 10
he's apologized for it and more than
that he's overhauled number 10. that has
already happened of course we wait to
see the outcome of the conclusion of the
met process and there will be an
opportunity then for an update on sue
gray's report and full transparency
around that yeah but i don't want again
no we don't want to yeah we know we know
in all the lies that hyperbole and and
talking about hypothetical questions all
that sort of question my question to you
was what is the significance of the
police statement from yesterday well the
20 individuals the law have been given
yes inevitably uh the fixed penalty
notice is those that have uh breached
the regulations and we uh stand by and
support the fact that there should be uh
the met process the the su grey process
uh and accountability for this yeah
because the prime minister of course
said previously all guidance was
followed completely
in number 10. how can that be true and
yet people also having broken the law
well i don't know i don't know the the
full facts um of the fixed penalty
notices and the details of those
individual cases but the prime minister
was uh telling the house of commons and
and the public uh what he knew to the
best of his ability we obviously had all
the questions the claims that were made
that's precisely why the supreme
inquiry was set up and that's why where
they've been credible allegations
they've gone to the police is precisely
because of those questions and those
challenges that those processes have run
their course and we of course support
that yeah but on at least 20 occasions
the law was broken at number 10 downing
street
where does the buck stop with that well
the pm's already said i mean um and
ultimately individuals take
responsibility but the pm has already
said he takes responsibility he
apologized for the fact that things
happen in number 10 that shouldn't have
done
and
more than that he's overhauled the
number 10 operation people have been
asking me already today yes but what
happens to those that have had a fixed
penalty note is many people have already
left number 10 downing street um and and
i think you can see from his actions and
the fact that these inquiries have taken
place that we uh believe engage indeed
embrace the transparency and the
accountability that that is that the
public rights yeah but the fact remains
deputy prime minister it's an actual
fact that 20 people broke the law in
downing street when we were in the
middle of a pandemic when people
couldn't bury their loved ones when they
couldn't see their loved ones in nursing
homes care homes and they died 20 people
broke the law who should be responsible
for that where does the book stop with
that well ultimately individuals we're
all responsible for what we do and
that's why uh the fixed penalty notices
the the appropriate punishment that the
met have handed out the pm has been
cleared that he uh uh recognizes that um
the the things went wrong he's
apologized for that um and and we've got
the ongoing process to determine any
other individuals both um through the
met police investigation anyone else
that has broken the law um and indeed
there will be an opportunity for sue
gray
and that inquiry to update their
findings and the pm's been very clear
there'll be full transparency around
that yeah but what does it say about the
culture when at least 20 people at least
20 fines have been issued so far more to
come we're told by them what does it say
about the culture at number 10 at the
time well look these things are deeply
regrettable what i would also say is
what does it say about the culture at
the time well i understand what you're
saying but on my experience and i was in
at number 10 we've had this conversation
before
was that look i'm not going to
excuse anything that happened that
shouldn't have done we've been very
clear about that though the punishments
have already been uh meted out but
mike's some of them some of them of
course accept that my experience and
just telling you honestly firsthand was
the incredible pressure and hard work
and dedication
of the overwhelming majority of people
working number 10. i'm always quite
careful um uh whilst engaging and
embracing the accountability that's
right take place to say that it's not
right to tar all the civil servants who
worked so hard during this panel not
doing that just saying well i think it's
fair because i because i don't accept um
that that the sort of caricature is
right i saw a lot of people working
incredibly long hours under incredible
pressure doing their very best
on 12 at least 12 occasions they broke
the law set 12 separate events we're not
talking about the prime minister
particularly because we don't know
whether he's got to find or not as yet
although we'll promise that he will and
i'm not going to ask you whether he
should step down or not because i know
what you're saying what i'm saying is
should we be anxious about the culture
of number 10 at the time well look i
think there clearly were things that got
wrong that's why the pm uh overhauled
the operation number 10 downing street
um
it's well known the the the individuals
that have come in and the individuals uh
at least some of them that have left um
and that's because he takes it so
seriously we do take it so seriously
what i'm just saying is that my
experience say this across government uh
and government gets things wrong and
civil servants and lord knows
politicians get things wrong as well if
you're asking me when i saw during the
pandemic huge number of people working
uh incredibly long hours on incredible
pressure to do the right thing okay just
before i let you go from friday if you
had a cough or a cold or other symptoms
that were flu-like would you test for
covert
uh it would me personally i i take a
judgment call on where i was going and i
think uh that's the common sense uh and
the process of getting back to living
with covid um and
uh us taking responsibility and do you
think that everybody should be able to
do that with a free lateral flow test
that we can't continue to provide the
natural flow tests uh uh free uh
in the way that we did before i think
there are a lot of emergency measures
which were quite quite right during the
midst of and the crucible of the
pandemic which we'll have to phase out
i'm afraid that that that follows and
that's because we've got all the other
things that we're funding as we build
back after the pandemic we've got the
covid backlog which the uh chancellor is
funded and the the health secretaries uh
is um
is tackling we i mean i know that we've
got the court recovery we've got all
those other things so it is part of the
transition out of the emergency pandemic
uh back to normal and i know we're out
of time but there is one other thing i
must just ask you about briefly and it's
the report that's coming out at 10
o'clock today as far as babies so many
babies having died i can't as a parent
you're a parent you can't even begin to
imagine the suffering that those parents
must have gone through how do you
reassure
pregnant women and their partners right
now today that they are safer safe to go
into hospitals to have their babies well
we do want to provide that reassurance i
can only imagine the heartbreak and then
the anxiety that spreads across
expectant mothers
and i think what you'll see is through
i'm sure it's the health secretary that
will be setting this out um a
the practical measures uh combined with
the recognition of what's gone wrong to
provide that reassurance
and confidence i think not just amongst
mothers but amongst the public at large
it is a really heartbreaking
series of
issues that we've had to grapple with